We're talking about corporate
stocks this time.
We've talked already about
them a little bit.
We talked about how people would
set up a corporation and
then divide it up into shares.
And then, the company grows,
more shares are issued, and
some people sell their shares.
It's a way of creating an
organization that works.
We talked about the first real
corporation with traded
shares, that was the Dutch East
India Company in 1602.
It was an idea that took hold
and became a scheme for
organization of business and has
become extremely important
around the world.
I actually had my own
personal experience.
I've created two corporations
in my life.
The first time, it was one of
my students here at Yale,
Allan Weiss.
Actually, he was not
an undergraduate.
He was getting an MBA from
the School of Management.
But he came to me after he
graduated and said, I see that
you create home price indexes.
I'd like to start a company
and sell them.
And so, he wanted me to
advise the company.
And then we decided to make
it a corporation.
We brought in my colleague, Chip
Case, who's at Wellesley
College, and it's called Case
Shiller Weiss Incorporated.
We brought in a fourth, a real
businessman, but he said it
would be ridiculous to have four
names on the company, so
he generously allowed
his name.
It's Chuck Longfield.
But then we set up the company,
and I remember
saying, I'm not going
to be that involved.
I'll be somewhat involved, but
I'm going to keep teaching at
Yale and I can't do more than
a day a week at most
or less than that.
So, we had to decide how
many shares we got.
The only guy who gave it money
was the businessman.
That's how you do it.
He put money into the company.
The rest of us just agreed
to put in time.
So, the question is, how do
we divide up the company?
Who gets how many shares?
The businessman put in money.
I'm putting in time.
How do we do that?
And I know I'm not going to put
in as much time as Allan
Weiss, who is actually
running the company.
But you know what we did?
We just divided it four
ways and we set it up.
And it's not a big company,
but I'm saying it, because
it's my own personal experience
having done this.
That was 1991.
We sold it in 2002 to Fiserv,
Inc. And at that time we had
12 employees.
It never got that big.
But then later on, S&P
bought the index.
The home price index is called
the S&P/ Case-Shiller Indices,
which are now quoted a lot.
I thought, it was a success.
It didn't get really big,
but it was a success.
One thing that I learned from
this experience is, have
appreciation for lawyers.
Because I had never funded a
company before and I didn't
know what kind of things
would happen.
Incidentally, in dividing up
the company, I think it was
just fairness.
We thought, we'll
all make our own
contribution in our own way.
We can't decide who's
more important.
But you know, honestly,
I didn't really
care about the money.
For me, it was just
a new experience.
It was like, we could all
be in this together.
We're all trying to make money
and making something big.
It was just a kind of a story
for me, that made it a little
bit of an adventure.
I was in it for the fun of it,
because I really don't feel
like I need any money.
I have a job.
I don't aspire to a mansion
or anything like that.
But we just did it.
It was fun.
The reason why I appreciated
lawyers is that they seemed to
anticipate all of our conflict
and they wrote things.
We had a corporate charter, a
long document, but it actually
made sense, because we did
get into some conflicts.
This is what happens
in a company.
Somebody isn't working as hard
as somebody else, and then
some resentment develops.
So, what do you do?
The salve is more shares.
If one guy's doing more than
another, it gets brought up at
the board meeting, and someone
says, well let's give this guy
more shares.
It's called a bonus, right?
So, we discovered the wisdom
of this system.
And I think a lot of people
around the world have
discovered it, and that's why
corporations are such an
important component
of our economy.
So, that's just my own personal
story, but I wanted
to talk about big and important
corporations, not mine.
But first, I wanted to give you
some sense of perspective
on how important corporations
are.
Corporate stock as traded
on stock markets.
So, I have data here from
the World Bank.
And that's the website.
You can get all the countries
of the world
from it if you want.
And the latest data
they have is 2008.
And for various countries or
various regions of the world
they have the value of the stock
market, of the listed
stocks in those countries in
trillions of U.S. dollars.
That's this column, the
trillions of dollars.
They also have the fraction of
GDP represented by the stock
markets in that country.
So, you can see that the biggest
stock market in the
world is the United States.
So, it's $11.7 trillion
in 2008 according
to the World Bank.
Second biggest is the euro-area,
$5 trillion.
And U.K. is very big, because
the United Kingdom was very
early to become a financial
center.
And it's an enormous financial
center now.
The interesting thing though
is as a fraction of GDP.
People are confused when we talk
about fraction of GDP,
because it's one year's GDP
we're talking about.
We're comparing a stock
with the flow.
A stock of wealth in the stock
market, dividing that by one
year's GDP.
So, it shows here that the
United States' stock market in
2008 was worth almost a year's
GDP and it was higher than any
other major country.
Again, this is a symbol
of capitalism.
If you want to invest in stocks
anywhere you live in
the world, you're going to
probably come to the United
States, because it's
much higher.
I mean, you could do Asia.
Asia and the Pacific, $3
trillion, but the U.S. is
almost four times as large.
That's because of the
long history.
This is a capitalist country.
And as I was saying, the New
York corporate law of 1811 got
this ball rolling, and so it
has led the world on that.
But I think if we look at this
chart again in ten 10 or 20
years, it's going to look
different, because stock
markets are growing around
the world, as a form of
organization for enterprise.
So, these numbers on the rest of
the world are all going up,
and we'll see more and
more value elsewhere.
And the reason is,
because it works.
The system coordinates
the activity.
It allows people to
work together.
And it allows them to avoid
conflicts and motivate people
to work and get things done.
And it creates wealth,
and people like that.
And so, it seems like something
that was learned.
We had a big grand experiment
with socialism obviously in
many places of the world, and
the socialists gave up on it.
They decided, this
works better.
That's why we have in China
now market socialism.
It's still socialism
in a sense.
It's transformed and it's
different, but it does have a
stock market and it's growing
rapidly there.
But I don't want to exaggerate
the importance of these,
either, because the total value
here for the United
States is only 82% of
one year's GDP.
Another way of putting
it is this.
Let's round that to $12
trillion, and there were about
300 million Americans in 2008.
That's $40,000 per capita
as the total value
of the stock market.
Now does that sound like
a lot of money to you?
Well, think of it this way.
For a family of four,
that's $160,000.
That won't buy you a house,
so it's not that big.
It's big, but it's
not that big.
What you have to remember is
that corporate stocks are
claims on the profits of
corporations, but most of what
corporations do is, take money
in and pay it out.
They pay it out to their
employees and to other people,
bondholders and taxes,
lots of other places
that money goes to.
So, the actual value of the
stock market, I think most
people exaggerate it
in their mind.
It's not that big.
It's big, but not that big.
It's smaller in other
countries.
You might wonder, why
is it that in Europe
it's only 38% of GDP?
That sounds funny, right?
In Europe, they're moving I
think in the direction of more
modern corporations with big
exchange traded corporations,
but they often do things on
a smaller scale still.
So, for example in Germany.
You notice that often companies
in Germany, after
the end of their name
they have AG.
That stands for
Aktiengesellschaft, and that
means stock market company.
But others have GmbH.
Do I have that capitalized
right?
Gesellschaft mit beschraenkter
Haftung.
That means a family company.
It's a company that's not traded
on the stock exchange.
What we're looking at here
are traded stocks.
Actually, my company that I was
just telling you about was
never traded.
That's called private equity.
If it's on the stock exchange,
it's public equity.
And if it's not traded,
it's private.
So, this is private,
and this is public.
And there are similar
distinctions in other
countries, but this
is Germany.
I just wanted to be clear
about one thing.
The word equity has many
different meanings, but the
meaning that we have here is
shares in a corporation.
I was curious about how far
back that term goes.
That word equity, referring to
shares, was not coined until I
think it was 1904 according to
the Oxford English Dictionary.
And it was American.
That's an American term that's
now spread over the world.
But we use equity.
I was trying to think, why
do we call it equity?
I think equity means equality
and fairness, and so, what it
means is, each share is equal.
I think that's what it means.
We're treating people
with equality.
So, that's what we have. We have
an equitable division of
profits among owners
of a corporation.
By the way, I was making
a comparison.
I said the value of shares in
the United States is $40,000
per capita, and it must be
much less in Europe, like
$20,000 or less of
traded stocks.
I just want to compare
that with houses.
I said $160,000 would be the
share of a family of four in
that value of the U.S.
stock market.
Actually, it is quite clear that
the value of houses in
the United States is greater
than the value
of the stock market.
According to the Federal
Reserve, the total value of
houses in the United States
in 2010 was $18 trillion.
That's quite a bit higher than
the value of the stock market.
Incidentally, the Federal
Reserve estimates the total
assets of households in the
United States, and in 2010
that was $69 trillion.
So, people own a lot of other
things besides stocks.
So, I'm minimizing the
importance of the topic of my
lecture, because stocks
aren't that valuable.
We couldn't solve the poverty
problem by redistributing the
stocks among all the people.
Suppose we did that,
all right?
Supposed we said, let's grab
all of the stocks away from
the wealthy people and let's
just share them equally among
the whole people.
So, some poor family would get
$160,000 one time only, right?
Remember, one time only.
It's a stock, it's not
a per year amount.
So, would that lift them
out of poverty?
Not if you have to live the rest
of your life on $160,000.
You'd still be in poverty.
So, the solution to poverty is
not redistributing stocks.
I think the solution to poverty
is instead making
these markets work better,
so that we produce more.
OK.
So, I'm going to talk about
stocks and the different kinds
of stocks and the laws of the
stock market here today.
And then, I'm going to come at
the end with a couple of
examples of companies.
I have an example of Xerox and
Microsoft, both high-flying
companies in their days.
Another term that I just want
to use is corporation.
Corporation comes from the Latin
corpus, meaning body.
The idea of a corporation
is like a legal person.
The lawyers say natural
person.
Each one of you is a natural
person, but there are
artificial persons as well, and
the corporation is called
an artificial person, even
though it really
only is owned by people.
It's like a slave belonging
to the shareholders.
So, that's the origin
of the term.
Actually, corporations go back
to ancient Rome where they
were called publicani, and they
had a stock market in the
Roman forum, but they were never
allowed to proliferate.
The laws encouraging them
did not create a
swell of new companies.
They were very few of them.
It wasn't until the 19th century
that corporations
really became important.
Now, a corporation is owned by
the shareholders, and in most
corporations all the
shareholders are equal.
That's why we call it equity.
And they all have one vote.
It's one share, one vote.
Not always.
There have been exceptions.
There are non-voting shares,
but usually they all vote.
And the idea is that the
shareholders vote to elect a
board of directors.
This is what they call
shareholder democracy.
It's inspired by political
democracy.
They were going to set up a
company that's democratic, but
it's not democratic in
that every person
has a right to vote.
It's each share has
a right to vote.
And so, that's the
essential idea.
When you form a company in the
United States, you have to
choose a state to
incorporate in.
And then, each state has
its own corporate laws.
So, my company, we did
it in Massachusetts.
A lot of people like to do it in
Delaware, because they like
those laws of Delaware and
the taxes of that state.
So, you choose, and then the
state will dictate some basic
rules, typically that you have
to have an annual shareholders
meeting where you vote.
That's the idea.
And you know, we did that.
I remember.
We followed the law.
Someone had a plan,
and it worked.
And so, what do you do at the
shareholders meeting?
Well, according to the bylaws in
the company, certain things
have to be decided there,
but not many.
The basic thing you
do is you hire a
chief executive officer.
You agree to hire that person.
And then this chief executive
officer reports to the board
as an employee of the company.
And in the U.S., the chief
executive officer has by
tradition often been named the
chairman of the board, but in
Europe, that's less likely.
There are some different
traditions in
the rest of the world.
A lot of people say it's not
good to have the CEO as
chairman of the board.
The board of directors
are not generally
working at the company.
The board of directors are
people who were brought
together to give wisdom
to the company.
And this is what happens.
You're setting up a company and
you don't know where to go
and what to do.
You need someone to
run the company.
That's the CEO.
And the CEO is probably a gung
ho guy who is going to work 80
hours a week and he's
ready to go.
But he needs guidance, he
or she needs guidance.
So, you get people with
different perspectives,
someone who ran a business years
ago and is retired or
any number of different
kinds of people.
And the board will meet more
regularly than the
shareholders.
Shareholders don't want to get
involved typically, because
they typically own
many companies.
They don't have time
to worry about it.
If you keep a board small
enough, so there's not too
many people, like 6 to 10
people, and they know
everything about the company,
they're privy to all the
information.
And they talk to each other at
regular big meetings and they
call each other up
on weekends.
It's part of the concept of a
director that you just take
responsibility for
this company.
You don't run it, but you're
responsible for it.
The law says in the United
States that if you join the
board of directors, you have
a duty of loyalty to the
shareholders.
That you were elected by the
shareholders to be on the
board, and you have a duty.
You may not own any shares
in the company.
Typically, you don't.
And a member of the
board is paid some
token amount of money.
You wonder why people do it.
They often do it just
to stay involved and
keep themselves learning.
They can make substantial money,
but they're not the
owners of the company.
They don't get rich by it.
They're the wise people
that were brought in.
You know, you joined
the board.
You're taking on a
responsibility.
You're not taking on a massive
You only meet a minimum, maybe,
of four times a year.
You'll be on phone calls.
But you have some
responsibility for the company.
And some people like that.
They sense that, well, I'm a
productive part of society.
I have this company.
I'll learn all about and think
about it in a broader
perspective.
So, that seems to work.
This sort of organization seems
to work really well.
You know what will happen?
The board will be talking
informally among themselves
and they'll say, is this CEO
really doing a good job?
And they think about it.
I want to just ask around
with our customers.
What do they think?
And so, someone might say, we
could just get a new CEO.
Let's do it.
And then the guy's out
immediately, if they vote at
the board meeting.
This is a structure that keeps
companies really good.
In one of the previous
semesters, I had Carl Icahn
come, who is a notorious
board breaker.
Well, he comes in --
he told our class here that he
likes to buy enough shares in
a company to get himself on the
board, and he loves to go
and show up at board meetings.
He buys companies, where there's
relatively ineffective
boards and the board is not
really paying attention.
They're kind of lazy.
And he comes in and makes
shocking statements, like fire
the CEO right now.
This guy's a loser.
And the board gets all
upset, because they
kind of like the guy.
It's cozy.
But Icahn says, you
know I can do it.
I go in there and I
lay it all out.
And it may take a
few meetings.
I can bring them around
and get the company
straightened out.
So, this is shareholder
democracy, how it works well.
Not everyone agrees with Carl
Icahn's interpretation.
He's a controversial guy.
Now, another thing I want to
say, there are basically two
kinds of corporations.
There's for-profit
and nonprofit.
I've been talking about
for-profit.
And all these people
[correction: companies]
I had on the screen as listed
shares are for-profit.
That means they have
shareholders.
There's another kind
of a corporation,
which is called nonprofit.
And we're standing
in one right now.
It's called Yale University.
It's a nonprofit corporation.
And it has a board
of directors.
They call it the Corporation.
They meet regularly.
It's like other corporations,
but there are no shareholders.
So, how can that be?
Who owns Yale?
Well, it's a person.
Yale University, like other
universities, is a legal
person, and its rights
are defined by law.
And the profits go back to Yale
and accumulate there and
are spent for a cause, namely
education and research.
So, the board of directors of
Yale has a different purpose.
They don't have any duty of
loyalty to shareholders,
because there are
no shareholders.
I mean we could call you
shareholders as students here,
but that's not what you're
called, and you don't have any
right to the profits.
The profits are spent
for good causes.
So, you wonder, well, those
two sound very different,
don't they?
Because a for-profit is trying
to make money, and the
nonprofit is doing something
for a cause.
That seems totally different.
But they're not always totally
different, because a lot of
what happens in corporations is
determined by the sociology
or the organizational
structure.
Some people serve on
multiple boards.
They'll be on Yale University
and they'll be on some other
company, for-profit, but the
same person probably behaves
similarly in both places.
So, oddly enough, for-profit
and nonprofit don't
often mean that much.
We're going to come back to
nonprofits later in this
semester, but I'm really talking
about for-profit.
Now, that sounds kind of
selfish in a sense.
A lot of us like nonprofits
better.
They have a different cachet
in our society.
I was talking to Peter Tufano,
who's a professor at Harvard
Business School, who set up
a nonprofit company called
''Doorways to Dreams.'' That's
the name of his company.
There's a website.
Search on Doorways to Dreams.
And it's all about finance for
the poor, the less represented
people.
And he said setting up a
nonprofit was the greatest
thing he ever did, because
it opens doors for him.
He walks in and says, I'm
running a nonprofit to benefit
poor people in the United
States, getting their
financial things in order.
He said, everyone respects me.
If I say I'm trying to make a
profit, they were skeptical.
We have one professor in our
econ department, Dean Karlan,
who set up a big nonprofit
at Yale.
That's kind of rare.
His is called ''Innovations for
Poverty Action.'' And just
last night, I had a door-to-door
surprise.
I had a young Yale freshman come
by asking me to donate
here in New Haven.
I guess Yale gets donations.
It's all ambiguous, but private
companies don't get
donations generally.
All right, the value of a share
in the company is equal
to the total value of the
company divided by
the number of shares.
So, the market cap of a company
is equal to the value
per share times the
number of shares.
Market cap is short for market
capitalization, and that is
the value of the company.
The key thing you have to know
about a company is, how many
shares are there and how
many shares do I have?
Maybe I'm repeating myself,
but if there's a million
shares outstanding and I own
1,000 shares, I own 1/1000 of
everything the company owns
after their debt.
But if there's 10 million shares
and I own 1,000 shares,
then I own only 1/10,000.
So, you have to know the
number of shares.
The number of shares that you
own is meaningless, unless you
know the total number of
shares in the company.
And all the different shares
are treated equally.
If they pay out any money to one
shareholder, they've got
to pay it out to all the other
shareholders in proportion to
the number of shares.
Now, companies issue
dividends.
A dividend is paid to
shareholders when the board of
directors decides to do it.
And the board of directors
doesn't have to do it.
I'm talking now exclusively
about for-profit, all right?
So, at a board meeting,
they can say,
hey, let's pay a dividend.
I remember this, because we had
exactly this meeting at
our little company.
We gave shares to all of our
employees to motivate them.
Everyone's a shareholder.
But they had tiny numbers.
Some of them had very
little shares.
And we had a board meeting and
we said, you know we've never
paid a dividend.
Should we do it?
Should we pay a dividend?
And then we had a discussion,
and someone said, well, you
know all these employees wonder
if their shares are
worth anything.
Maybe, if they got a check in
the mail, they'd feel better.
But you see, the dividend is
subject to the discretion of
the company.
Ultimately, people own shares
to get dividends.
The dividend is the distribution
of profits.
If a company never distributed
dividends, it would be like a
nonprofit --
if they kept all the profits.
They can do that.
There's no law saying
that they have
to distribute dividends.
They can just keep it in the
company and, like Yale
University, get a huge endowment
and just let it get
bigger and bigger.
But the whole purpose
of a for-profit
company is to pay dividends.
And so, sooner or later they
do it, but typically young
companies don't pay dividends.
Why not?
Because everybody knows that
our money is in the future.
We're starting up.
We're not making
a lot of money.
In the future, we'll have a
lot of money, so let's pay
dividends later.
For example Microsoft, that I'm
going to describe, went
through decades without ever
paying a dividend.
They just kept plowing it
back into the company.
Now, if you knew that they would
never pay a dividend,
then you wouldn't want to
own Microsoft shares.
But you think, well, eventually
they're going to,
so that's why you
own the company.
This is a very common
misunderstanding.
A lot of people think that you
buy stocks because the price
will go up.
Well, the price will go up
only because people think
there are more dividends
coming.
At least in theory, that's
the way it should be.
The price ought to be --
and we'll question
this later --
the present value of expected
future dividends.
So, the true value
of a company is
entirely in the dividends.
It seems a little funny, because
you think, well, the
board of directors doesn't have
to pay a dividend and
they could just get nasty
and never pay it out.
But remember, you elect the
board of directors.
And so, if you're frustrated
that our company is
accumulating lots of money and
it's not paying it out.
I want the money, right?
So, I'm not going to vote
for this board.
I'll put Carl Icahn on
or someone else.
Pay it out.
And then that's what happens,
they start paying it out.
When they pay out a dividend,
the share price falls
generally, right?
Very simple.
Why would the share price fall
when they pay out a dividend?
Well, because the company
is worth less.
They had this money and they
paid it out, so it should fall
by the amount they paid
out divided by
the number of shares.
And companies do
that routinely.
When they declare a dividend,
price falls.
It's called the ex-dividend
price, and they show it in
newspapers.
They used to show it
in newspapers.
Now, it would be
on the website.
They put a little x by the stock
price on the day after a
dividend is paid to tell you
that the price decline that
you just saw is not anything
to worry about.
It doesn't mean there's bad
news about the company.
It just means they just
paid a dividend.
So, the price routinely
goes down by the
amount of the dividend.
It doesn't mean anything.
Some stockbrokers have tried
to alarm investors about
dividend payment dates
and mislead them.
Some stockbrokers would say,
why don't you buy the stock
right now, because if you
buy it right now,
you'll get a dividend.
They're going to pay a dividend
in three days.
Hurry up and buy it and you'll
get the dividend.
That's called selling dividends
and it's considered
unethical for a broker ever to
tell you that, because it
really doesn't matter.
Because if you buy it later,
you won't get the dividend,
but you'll get the
share cheaper.
And it all comes out
to about the same.
You don't have to worry about
dividend payment dates,
because the stock price jumps
down right after a dividend.
Except maybe for some
second-order effects, it
doesn't matter whether you buy
before or after a dividend.
All right, so, you see
the idea here.
The idea of a corporation is we
have these shares, and the
shares are always salable.
So, let's say four of us young
people form a company.
And then after a couple of
years, one of us says, I've
got another job.
I'm tired of this.
I want out.
And you say, fine.
We'll buy your shares back.
And we agree on a price.
So, it's very fair and easy.
People can get in and
out as they please.
And the only people involved
are people
who want to be involved.
And then you'll find
some new person.
The four of us set
up a company.
There's some new guy who
just heard of us.
And he thinks, this
a great idea.
I want in.
So, then you say, all right.
We'll sell you shares
in the company.
But maybe the price
has changed.
When we started, we might have
been worth a lot less.
The guy has to come in at a new
price, and the price is
changing every day.
It makes very good sense.
So moreover, if the company
needs to raise money to do
business --
So, we've started a company
and we need to build a new
factory, let's say, to
expand our operation.
Well, we can go out
and issue more
shares to buy the factory.
So, we go to a stockbroker,
who is like a real estate
broker, who deals in
markets for shares.
I'm talking about a small
company, so I'm thinking of a
private company for which
there's no stock market price.
But the stockbroker can go out
and say, I'll find a buyer.
I have various contacts.
I know people who deal with
wealthy individuals looking
around for an investment.
Maybe this person will buy some
shares, and then you'll
get the money.
That's an alternative.
That's called equity
financing.
That's an alternative to
financing by debt.
Your company could also go to
a bank and ask for a loan,
called a corporate loan.
Or your company could borrow
money on the bond market, by
issuing bonds.
You can go to a broker
and say, we want to
sell corporate bonds.
But the difference of those is
that it's at a fixed interest
rate and it's not a share
in the profits.
So, equity financing tends to
attract lively investors who
take risks.
If a company gets debt, then the
debt leverages up the risk
of the company, because you as
a shareholder now are paid
only after the debtors
are paid.
You own the value of the
company, which is the assets
minus the liabilities,
as a shareholder.
But you've got to subtract
off the liabilities.
So, companies have a choice
of how to finance their
operations.
Typically they start
out with equity.
I guess they could start out
with debt as well, but in our
case of our little company, it
was all equity at first, and
then we got bank loans and so
we started to get leveraged.
And that's what happens.
Big companies do
the same thing.
I'd like to talk about the
simple company that you might
set up with your friends,
because it seems so personal
and you can imagine
doing that, right?
You can imagine the kind of
conflicts that you would have.
But these little companies have
a way of growing really,
really big.
So, I'm going to talk about a
little company set up by Bill
Gates and Paul Allen in 1975.
Bill Gates was an undergraduate
at Harvard and
he saw an opportunity
and he dropped out.
He was right.
He never got his
Harvard degree.
I suggest that if you see such
an opportunity, you do the
same thing.
I hate to say it.
If you can see an opportunity
like that.
It started out with just
Bill and Paul and
their little company.
But they have a way to grow into
bigger and bigger things.
The question is, are they
really different later?
So, one important question is
about whether big companies
really use equity financing.
Are they still functioning
the way I'm describing?
See, I set the idea of a company
up as a structure that
lawyers invented that allows
people to work together and
allows them to get in and
out of the company.
Does it really still work that
way for really big companies?
There's been a complaint about
the stock market, that the
companies generally don't issue
any more shares once
they're big.
This is a complaint.
I'm not saying it's right.
And that the stock market
ends up as a market
for existing shares.
The idea is, are the stock
markets of the world
functioning to make capitalism
work better?
Well, I could say, they should
be, because the price of a
share of a company is an
indicator of the value of the
company and it directs
resources.
I mean, people look at that
price and they decide where to
invest. But if they're
not issuing any more
shares, does it matter?
I had a quote from
Karl Marx here.
You've heard of Karl Marx,
the founder of communism.
In his book, Capital, Das
Kapital, his classic
work, he said: --
I'm quoting Marx --
"Since property here exists
in the form of stock, its
movement and transfer become
purely a result of gambling on
the stock exchange, where the
little fish are swallowed by
the sharks and the lambs
by the stock
exchange wolves." OK.
That was Marx's view, but even
in communist countries, that
view doesn't seem to be
holding sway anymore.
The thing that lent some
credibility to these theories
is that it often seems that big
companies don't issue many
shares anymore.
I'm going to qualify that.
But there was a very influential
article written by
Stewart Myers, who's a professor
of finance at MIT.
And that was in the Journal
of Finance in 1984.
And he gave some statistics.
This was an influential article,
making it sound like
shares don't really matter
for a big company.
He said, how do companies really
finance their needs?
And he came up with data.
This is Myers's data
from 1973 to 1982.
And he found that 62% of
corporate financing needs came
from, in the United States,
retained earnings.
What he's saying is, companies
didn't sell new shares, they
just accumulated profits.
And then, when they had to build
a new factory, they went
to their own piggyback and they
bought the new factory or
whatever it was they needed.
And only 6% was equity issued.
This is for the whole
U.S. stock market.
And the rest was debt that they
would borrow money for.
So, Stewart Myers said, you know
all this idea that stock
markets function to allocate
resources and the share market
means something is really
misleading.
So, what he proposed is
what he called the
Pecking Order Theory.
What he meant is, companies
really don't want
to issue new shares.
They just don't want to do it.
We own this company.
We're not letting
more people in.
So, what they first do
is they just try to
save their own money.
This is Myers' explanation.
Companies save money and when
they have money, they spend it
on expanding.
That's the highest on
the pecking order.
They like that the best. But if
they really need money and
they can't save enough to
expand, they have a lot of
expansion opportunity.
They'll go to a bank
and borrow.
They'll go to an investment
bank and issue bonds.
And then, only if it's really,
really important and they
can't get enough money,
they will go to
selling their shares.
So, I don't know if Stewart
Myers said Karl Marx was
right, but he seemed to be
saying that equity issuance
just wasn't that important.
However, I think that
is misleading.
I'm going to refer now to
another article that came in
much later criticizing Myers.
And the article is by Eugene
Fama and Kenneth French, at
Chicago and Dartmouth
respectively.
They wrote an article in 2005.
This is in the Journal of
Financial Economics in 2005.
They said that the problem with
Myers's Pecking Order
Theory is that Myers was looking
at aggregate data and
he was looking at a time
period when there was
relatively little issuance
of equity.
When Myers said only 6% of
corporate financing comes from
equity issuance, they were
talking about net equity,
that's total new sales of shares
by companies minus
repurchases of shares
by companies.
And so, it averaged out
to be a low number.
But in fact, as Fama and French
point out, in the same
years that Myers studied, from
1973 to '82, 67% of U.S.
companies issued new
shares each year.
And also in subsequent years,
the percentage went up.
From 1993 to 2002, it was 86%.
So, they're all issuing
shares.
It's just that some
are issuing and
some are buying back.
So, I think that we should
conclude that companies really
do use equity financing,
even big companies.
And the stock market
is important
for the price discovery.
I wanted to remind you
of the term dilution.
Dilution refers to what happens
when a company issues
more shares.
So, imagine that you
are showing up at a
shareholders meeting.
The board has decided
to issue --
Let's say our company has a
million shares outstanding.
They've decided to
issue another
million at $10 a share.
And so, what do you
think about that?
Well, if the company had a
million shares, and I owned
1,000 shares, then I own 1/1,000
of the company, right?
If they issue another million
shares, then there'll be two
million shares, and I'll own
only 1/2,000 of the company.
So, my first thought is
I don't like that.
I owned 1/1,000 of the
company, and now
I'm falling in half.
But they would say, on the
other hand, look, we're
selling them for $10 a share,
so the company will have $10
million to invest. So, even
though your fraction of the
company has been diluted, the
company is worth more.
Then, you have to decide whether
$10 a share is a good
enough price.
Is it worth that?
And so, it's never obvious.
You always have to consider
dilution, because anything
that expands the number of
shares decreases your interest
in the company.
The opposite of dilution occurs
when the company buys
back its shares.
That's repurchase of shares
by a company.
A company can always do that.
They can decide to
go either way.
If they need more money, they
can issue shares, and if they
want to get money out, they
can buy back shares.
And these things are
very common.
There are statistics, like what
Fama and French showed
for equity issuance,
which show that
repurchases are very common.
And it happens all the
time in the market.
That's what makes the stock
market so active.
One reason traditionally
for share
repurchases is tax reasons.
If a company pays a dividend,
that goes in as income to the
shareholders and it's taxed.
It used to be taxed at a higher
rate than capital
gains, so there was an
advantage to share
repurchases.
Instead of paying dividends, I
should just buy back shares.
And then the shareholders would
have a better tax --
they would be taxed at a
more advantageous rate.
But now the tax rate on
dividends and the tax rate on
capital gains is the same, but
still there's always going to
be complicated tax issues.
And so, issues of taxation may
still motivate some decisions
about share repurchase.
But you have to understand that
it's getting money out of
the company.
And as a shareholder, if the
company wants to send me a
dividend, I say fine,
I've got money.
If the company says I want to
buy some of your shares back,
you say fine, I've got money.
I don't care.
And so, if they buy back 5% of
all their shares, then the
total number of shares
goes down.
My fraction of the company is
the same [correction: the
fraction increases],
and I've got money.
It's the same as getting
a dividend.
So, you can be confused
by these things.
Dilution and repurchase are
neither good nor bad.
It depends on circumstances.
And you have to look at the
business and what's being done
with the money.
I wanted to mention, there's
another kind of
share called preferred.
I've been talking here
about common stock.
Common stock is the real
ownership in the company.
In other words, you take
all the profits.
They're the ultimate owners
of the company.
Nobody is above them
in the hierarchy.
But there's something
close that's
considered close but different.
It's called preferred stock.
And preferred stock has
a set dividend.
The contract says that the
dividend is so many dollars
per year, and the board doesn't
have to pay it.
But typically, the contract
says they cannot pay a
dividend to the common
shareholders until all the
dividends to the preferred
shareholders are paid up.
And the preferred shareholders
typically don't have a vote.
OK.
So, this is it.
You could buy preferred stock
in some company and then you
would know exactly what
your dividend is.
Usually, they just
pay a dividend.
It's like owning a bond.
And it's always the
same amount.
So, you're not betting on the
company doing better or worse
generally, but if it does badly,
you might lose your
dividend for a while.
If a company goes bankrupt,
well, then you're out.
But if the company starts doing
well again, they've got
to go back and make up for all
the dividends they missed.
So, preferred shares are safer
than common shares, but they
lack the upside potential.
They're not as exciting
as common shares.
So, when General Motors got
into a crisis, the U.S.
government bailed out
General Motors.
What they did was
to buy preferred
shares in General Motors.
So, the U.S. government was
a preferred stockholder in
General Motors.
Why did the U.S. government
do that?
Why did they buy preferred
shares rather than common?
Well, they now do have common
shares as well.
I think the government wanted
to not be a stockholder, not
to be a voter in GM.
They wanted to keep
their distance,
because this is America.
This is a capitalist country.
If the U.S. bought common shares
in General Motors, it's
like nationalizing the
company, right?
The government would
be on the board.
They would have the votes.
They just didn't want to go
that far, so they bought
preferred shares in
General Motors.
Later, General Motors got on its
feet again and bought back
the government's preferred
shares.
So, the government is no longer
a preferred shareholder
in General Motors.
Common is much more important
than preferred.
OK.
Now, I'm going to talk a little
bit about dividends.
What determines whether
a firm pays dividends?
There's a famous article
by John Lintner.
John Lintner was a professor at
the Harvard Business School
and also one of the inventors
of the Capital
Asset Pricing Model.
He wrote an article in --
when was it?
It was a long time ago --
about why firms pay dividends.
Remember, it's a judgment call
by the board of directors.
So, he interviewed people who
were involved in those
judgments and asked them, why
do you pay dividends?
Why did you decide to pay a
dividend of a certain amount?
And he wrote a long article
about this.
And he found out that it was
impossible to summarize
everything they said.
They said so many different
things.
Corporations are very complex,
and there's a lot of different
people, who have different
feelings.
And we're trying to
keep people happy.
And you want the company to do
well and be perceived well.
One thing he learned is that
companies think that our job
is to pay dividends.
You don't have to earn
an income now.
You're young, right?
Eventually people are going to
get fed up with you if you
don't earn an income.
So, it's the same thing.
As a company matures, it's
part of life's passage.
You start paying dividends and
you take pride that you're
paying dividends and people are
getting money out of you.
You hear a lot of generalities
like that,
but what really decides?
And one thing he learned from
them is, they told him, you
know one thing we don't
ever want to
do is cut our dividends.
Once we start paying a dividend,
if we stopped, it'll
get a lot of attention.
Well, it's like for you.
You're young people.
You don't have a job.
Nobody is complaining.
You could go for a while
like this and say,
you're still young.
But once you start at a job and
then you quit, it looks
bad, right?
If you're 40 years old and you
say, I'm just dropping out, it
looks worse than if you
do it at your age.
It's the same for companies.
Once they start paying a
dividend, they've got
to keep paying it.
Otherwise people get angry.
So, that was one theme.
But Lintner said, even that
doesn't tell the whole story.
So, he tried to build a
mathematical model of dividends.
And the model that he came up,
which he then fit to the data,
and found that it worked very
well, was that these boards of
directors have a target payout
ratio of earnings basically.
This is the bottom line.
They think they should pay out
a certain fraction of their
earnings, because the
shareholders will get mad if
we're making a lot of
money and we're not
sharing it with you.
So, maybe we'll pay out half of
our earnings, and the other
half we'll keep as retained
earnings so that we don't have
to go out and issue new equity
or borrow money.
It all sounds reasonable.
And then, because they don't
like to cut a dividend, they
don't want to adjust upward
quickly if earnings shoot up.
Because, if they go up and raise
their dividend, then
they might have to cut it if
earnings go back down.
So, this is the Lintner model.
And it is that the dividends
at time t --
year t, let's say -- minus
dividends at year t minus one
equals rho times a number
tau -- that's the
Greek letter tau --
times earnings per share minus
dividend per share at time t
minus one plus noise.
And tau is between 0 and 1.
So, they have some fraction
of earnings that
they want to pay out.
And if earnings per share
rise, so that tau times
earnings per share is greater
than dividends, then they
increase their dividends.
And rho is between 0 and 1.
That's the Lintner model.
And he showed with the data that
it pretty much summarizes
what firms are doing.
So, they have a payout ratio
out of earnings.
And the payout ratio
has been declining
over the last century.
It used to be typically
60% to 70%.
In 1900, shareholders were
impatient with companies.
They wanted to see the
money, but they let
them keep 30% or 40%.
But now we've become more and
more believers in the stock
market and we allow companies
to do better things.
So, I said I would
talk about some
examples of specific companies.
Let me get back to
my slides here.
I wanted to start with Xerox.
Xerox Corporation, you've
heard of it?
You've heard of Xerox?
It's still there.
It exists.
Xerox Corporation was
founded in 1906.
It wasn't called Xerox.
It was called the Haloid
Photographic Company, and they
produced photographic
equipment.
But they had a big impetus
forward when they met Chester
Carlson, who was an inventor.
And what Chester Carlson
invented was a copying machine
that used plain paper.
They used to have copying
machines going all the way
back to 1906, but they
were very expensive.
To get a copy of something, a
photographic copy, it would
cost you maybe $1 a page, which
was extremely expensive
for that time.
But what Carlson invented
was a dry copier.
It used to be that what they
had to do was take a
photograph of the document that
you wanted a copy of and
then process it through
the different
chemicals that they use.
It comes out wet, and you
have to hang it out.
That was expensive
and inconvenient.
They did have copying machines,
they just didn't
work very well.
But he invented this process
that you could take any paper
and put it through, plain paper,
and it would come out
hot and dry, and cheap.
So, Xerox became an overnight
success, because they had a
patent on Carlson's thing.
It became the glamour company
of the 1960's and 1970's.
So, it was one of
the Nifty Fifty.
People were very impressed
with Xerox in its day.
So, Xerox means dry in Greek.
It's a dry copier.
And it was considered a high
tech company, moving forward
rapidly, but then it
suffered a problem.
Do you know what the
problem was?
It was doing really well, until
sometime in the 1990's
when another invention came.
And it wasn't Xerox's.
It's called digital copying
machines, where the machine
would have a computer that would
scan in the document and
then produce a copy.
And it had a lot of advantages
over the Xerox copier.
So, the company almost
went under.
What I've got here
is the balance
sheet from Xerox Company.
And this comes from a website,
sec.gov. And I got this from
the 10-Q report.
Xerox is a public company,
not a private company.
It's traded on stock
exchanges.
So, U.S. law says, any public
company must file a quarterly
report with the Securities and
Exchange Commission, and they
put it up on their website.
This is the website.
So, any public company's balance
sheet is on the web.
And it's there updated
every three months.
And I've got a couple
of them here.
I've got 1999 and 2010.
My little company, Case Shiller
Weiss Incorporated, it
was not public, so our balance
sheet was never up there on
sec.gov. That's one of the
disadvantages, many people
say, of becoming public.
If you start out as a private
company and you want to get
listed on the stock exchange,
that's called going public.
When you go public, the SEC is
on your back and it says, you
now have to file those quarterly
balance sheets.
So, this is what I've got.
So, this is Xerox, and it's all
up there on sec.gov. I've
got it for 1999.
This was right at the time
when they were really in
trouble, because the digital
revolution was killing Xerox.
And I just wanted to show a
balance sheet of a company,
because there's two sides
to the balance sheet.
There's assets and
liabilities.
Assets are things the
company owns.
Liabilities are debts
the company has.
So, this is one side of the
balance sheet, but I've got it
for two years.
And everything is in millions.
Xerox had $126 million in cash
in 1999 and they picked up.
The company was dying in 1999.
In 2001, they hired a new CEO,
Anne Mulcahy, and she is
credited with saving Xerox,
turning the company around.
So, by 2010, at least in terms
of cash, they are doing
better, but maybe not
a lot better.
She saved it from extinction,
but she didn't move it back on
to the Nifty Fifty.
So, I just wanted to look at
what a company owns, and this
is just an example of
a balance sheet.
So, Xerox owned $15 billion
of receivables in 1999.
It was a much lower
number in 2010.
I don't know.
It might reflect time of
the year or something.
Receivables is money that's
owed to them.
They ship their copying
machine to someone.
The guy says, I'll pay
you in three months.
That's a receivable.
And they had inventories.
That means, probably, copying
machines ready to be sent out.
And they own buildings.
The buildings, it looks like
it went down under Mulcahy.
It went down from $2.4 billion
to $1.6 billion.
And then, there's a lot
of other things.
So, the value of everything that
the company owns wasn't
much changed.
$28.8 billion went up
to $30 billion.
So, at least she stopped the
company from failing.
But now that's only half
of the balance sheet.
I have to go to the
other half.
And these are the liabilities.
This is what the company owes.
So, it has short-term debt.
Let's talk about 2010.
$1.6 billion.
Long-term debt of
$7.8 billion.
Deferred taxes.
That means taxes that they know
they have to pay that
they haven't paid.
They didn't have any in 2010.
And preferred stock.
They did have a small amount
of preferred stock
outstanding, which counts
as a liability.
All right.
And then, other liabilities.
I put them all into
one category.
Now, this last liability
is unique,
because it's the residual.
It's called shareholders'
equity.
This number, the total
liabilities, has to equal the
total assets.
This is the same number
that I showed you on
the preceding page.
What's the difference?
It's the shareholders equity.
OK?
So, it's $11.9 billion in 2010,
up from $4.9 billion.
So, by this measure,
it's a success.
Now what is shareholders'
equity?
Is this the value
of the company?
No, it's the value of the
company on the books.
So, according to
their books --
I'll go back to it.
They have all these
assets, including
buildings and equipment.
Where did they come up
with this number?
How do they know what
their buildings and
equipment are worth?
It's an estimate, because
who knows what they
could sell them for.
So, in principle, this
shareholders' equity is what
the shares are worth, all of
the shares, $11.9 billion.
Because if you bought the
company and you sold all the
assets and paid off all
the debts, that's
what would be left.
So, you divide that by the
number of shares and you can
get an estimate of the
value of a share.
But I say an estimate.
It's not the same as
the market value.
In 2010, there were
1.4 billion shares
outstanding in Xerox.
The price per share
of a Xerox common
share in 2010 was $11.80.
So, if I multiply the number
of shares by the price per
share, the market cap for
Xerox is $16.4 billion.
Compare that with the
shareholders'
equity of $11.9 billion.
So, the company is worth more
than its shareholders equity.
And you might ask, why
would that be?
OK?
Well, I think the answer is, you
wouldn't buy this company
to shut it down.
You could buy the company for
$16 billion and then shut it
down, sell off all the assets,
pay off all the debts, and
you'd have $11 billion.
So, that's a sign of Anne
Mulcahy's success.
Her company is not going
to be shut down.
If the stock price falls below
the shareholders' equity, it
becomes at risk for
being shut down.
Somebody buys the company and
shuts it down, because I can
make money.
If the company were
selling for $5
billion, I might do that.
Well, not me.
Somebody who arranges these
things could do that.
So, I buy the company
for $5 billion.
I tell everybody, you're
all fired.
We're going out of business.
I sell it.
I get $11.9 billion.
I've doubled my money.
All right.
Now, a company can sell for less
than the shareholders'
equity, because the
shareholders' equity is kind
of a funny number.
It's also called stockholders'
equity by some
people, same thing.
It's a funny number,
because it involves
all kinds of estimates.
And if you really try to sell
that real estate for what it
says here, you might
find problems.
So, the market capitalization
can follow below shareholders'
equity, but probably
not too far below.
And this is what worries
boards and CEOs.
They watch their stock price
every day and they've got in
their mind that shareholders'
equity.
And if the stock is falling
below that, then they're in
danger of liquidation.
So, they worry.
And that's why every morning, if
you are a CEO, if you're a
CEO of a public company, you
will be watching your market
cap every day and comparing that
with shareholders equity.
So, Xerox is an example
of a company that's
doing all right now.
I'll show you its price.
I don't have it all the way
back to 1906, but this is
Xerox price per share, and it's
corrected for splits and
other special factors,
from 1977 to 2001.
And you can see the incredible
crash they took after digital
copying came in.
In the 1990's, they
were soaring.
They looked great.
They must have been doing
something right, but they had
their heyday and it's over.
So, Anne Mulcahy came in when
the company was utterly
collapsing, and I guess
she's a success.
But it's not its former self,
it's limping along.
I wanted to tell you now
about Microsoft.
So, that was founded
in 1975 by two
people your age, I guess.
As of 2000, it had assets
totaling $52 billion, and in
the last ten years, it's almost
doubled it, so its
assets are $92 billion.
What does it own?
Well, it has cash of about
$4 billion or $5 billion.
Short-term investments, a lot of
short-term investments, $37
billion of short-term
investments.
This is a company that's
doing well.
It's not on the end
of its life.
And it has property.
They have this nice campus
in Redmond, Washington.
They call it a ''campus.''
It's fun.
Fun place.
Anyway, it's not
that expensive.
All of their real estate now is
only about $8 billion, and
that's all of their computers
and equipment.
And then, they own stock.
This is really different
from Xerox.
Xerox doesn't own any stock.
They're trying to limp by.
They're trying to get
back in stride.
Maybe they have gotten
But they've got $10 billion
in the stock market, other
companies they own.
They own all sorts of stuff.
This is a company that didn't
pay a dividend until recently.
And Bill Gates and Paul Allen
were still there running it.
Maybe there's a little
bit of truth in this
Pecking Order Model.
They just wanted to save their
own money and they thought
their shareholders
would understand.
Microsoft is doing so well.
Are you really expecting us
to pay you a dividend out?
We have all of these
opportunities, so
we'll keep the money.
And people had enough faith in
these guys to let them do it.
So, by this account, the total
assets to the company were $92
billion, but we have to
look at liabilities.
Remember, the shareholders'
equity subtracts off
liabilities.
So, here are their
They have some income taxes that
have to be paid, but it's
only $1 billion.
That's like small
change, right?
It's because of some
timing effects.
Accounts payable, this is some
money that they owe.
They do owe money, because every
company delays paying
their bills for a little
while anyway.
So they had something.
Unearned revenue.
Typical case is, they've
sold a Windows system.
They've got the money, but they
really haven't completely
earned it yet, because you're
going to be calling up with
complaints and they're going
to have to do things in the
future for the revenue that
they've already earned.
So, they count that
as a liability.
They didn't have any
debt in 2000.
This is strange, right?
You think they were making
so much money,
why should they borrow?
For some reason, it's now
up to about $10 billion.
I can't explain that.
And so, you add all these up
and subtract them from $92
billion and their shareholders'
equity is $48 billion.
So, they're doing pretty well.
They're much bigger.
But is that the way to
measure Microsoft?
This is a measure
of the value.
It's really the liquidation
value of Microsoft.
So, you could imagine buying
Microsoft and then selling all
those assets, shutting it
down, firing everybody.
Would that be a smart
thing to do?
You fire everybody.
You sell the Redmond campus.
You sell all of their
computers.
And what do you end up
with? $48 billion.
Well, let's compare that with
the market cap of Microsoft.
They have 8,497 million shares
outstanding, and the price per
share at the end of
2010 was $26.
So, the market cap
is $221 billion.
So, that's over five times their
shareholders equity.
That means that they have
some other value.
I think I'm running
out of time.
It's interesting what happens
in the world.
I'll stop with this.
This is the price per
share of Microsoft.
I should disclose.
I'm now a shareholder.
I wish I were a shareholder
back then.
Nobody believed it.
This only goes back
to '86, but the
company maybe was private.
I forget when it went public.
So, we don't have prices
[addition: before '86],
but we have prices in '86.
It really had a run until 2000,
and then something broke
with Microsoft as well.
It looks a little bit like
Xerox, doesn't it?
I think it was the end of
the high tech bubble.
This was a bubble in
tech prices, and
Microsoft rode the bubble.
But it's still doing
very well.
It's just not going up lately.
Anyway, this is an example.
We're going to talk about real
estate, the other asset class
that I've mentioned, which is
even bigger than the stock
market, in our next lecture
on Wednesday.